Háu mời nó mùi nhìn chi trà 4 mấy làm, trong bài viết chống nạn thất học, đặc trì bảo nữ quốc, số 5 mấy tảm,
chú tên hồ chí mình nèu gióc, một trong những câu viện phải thực hiện các tấp lúc này là nân cao dân chi,
muốn giữ phượng nền được lật, muốn làm cho sân mạnh nước giấu, mọi người Việt Nam phải hiểu biết quyền lợi của mình,
bồn phận của mình, phải có kiến thức mới để có thể tham gia và công cuộc sư dự nước nhà,
và trước hết phải biết đọc biết biết chi cũng ngữ, và người kiêu gọi những người đã biết trước,
hãy dạy cho những người cho biết trước, những người cho biết trước, hãy gắn sức mà học cho biết đi,
và ở trên biết thì trong bào, em cho biết thì anh bào, chá mẹ không biết thì có bào, người ăn người làm không biết thì chủ nhà bào,
tất người dầu có thì mở lấp học ở tư gia, dạy cho những người không biết trước ở hàng sống lắng dường.
Lời kêu gọi của bác về nhemp vụ chống sạch sốt đã nhìn chống thấm sâu và tâm chỉ của mọi người dân,
làm thức dậy làm tự tôn dân tầm và thị só chính nghiệm của mình.
Những người biết trước, dạy người chỉ biết trước, những giấu viên chuyện bà của người khu,
thang viên học sinh sinh viên công trước, thứ nào sinh đều viên tên dạy và làm tin chuyện viên.
Lấp học khắp nơi, học chiếc học chiếc học tối, chỉ một năm sau ngày nhà bị rinh dân học vụ từ thành lập,
bởi vì làm nghiên lớp học được mở với hơn 50 nghìn giáo viên,
kết quả có hơn 2 chiệu năm 2020 thó nạn ngủ chứ?
Và hơn thế, từ những ngày đầu tiên của công cuộc chiến đấu vi giật giốt,
như dựa tà đã sắc định, học không chỉ để sóa ngủ chứ mà đó là việc cuộc cà đời.
Chỉ mọi miền của đất nước, tự nông thôn đến thành thịt, từ miền suôi đến miền đối biệt giới hại đạo,
tờ người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài, hàng ngày thâm xa vào quá trình sáo dụng giản dầy học tật.
Để phát triển đất nước, hội nhập với thế giới?
Kết thúc năm 2018, hành hiểu của Trump 2022, cả nước có chính nghiệm năm 2020, trên mời yên năm 2014, việc chấn được đánh giá sếp loại tục đồng học tập cấp sáng.
Mời sống nghiệm 804 cơ quan đường viết cấp viện cấp tình, đặt đơn vị học tập.
Năm 20 2020, thành phố XI ming và thành phố Sơn là tình xưa là đất công nhận là thành viên mặng lưới thịt phỏ tập của UNESCO.
Gặp mặt thân bật với đoạn đại biểu cán bộ, hội khuyến thập tư biểu gặn cốt, sáng ngày 11 năm 2020.
Chua tính nước lớn cường, đề nghĩ mỗi người không kẹt tội tác, địa viết xá hội, khá il luôn thoại học tập, lạc quyền lời, lại chất nghiệm và nghĩa phụ của mình.
Ngày nay, để đáp ứng yêu cầu trong tiền tình bởi, phòng trào bình rất thật vụ số, yêu cầu mọi người phải học thường xuyên học xuất đời, không chỉ học chữ mà phải học, đến 5 phứng khoọt công nghệ đổi mới sáng tạo chuyển đôi số.
Học nè, học để làm người để làm việc, chung sống và cùng phát triển là cộng đồng, khó phần giữ dìm phát viên chuyển thống hiểu khọt của rất tổ phía tên năng, ngàn 5 phân tiến và anh hùng.
Rồi đề nhất, trước thêm 5 phọt mới thành nghệ cũng chăm hay 1 năm, thành nghệ cũng chăm hay 1 sấu, tổng ý thư tổ lâm đặc kiế bằng hàng nghiệp quyết bệm mốt, nở quy tế u của bộ chính trị, về độ phát phát triển sấu dục và đạo tạo.
Hỉnh cứ đề cập tế việc nân cạo trên lượng lội vốn sáo viên đổi mới chính trình, thống nhất bộ rất sốc phua, tăng cường trải nghiệm học tập, ứng dục mạnh mẽ chuyển đổi số, tất cả những lộu xung này đều nhằm hiện thực hóa một tiêu dài hạn, năng tập lên sấu dục việt năng.